her real voice they have one about her
real voice
okay there was this kid there was this
kid named tyler schultz that worked for
her
and her his granddad his grandpa was the
secretary of state george schultz who
was one of the biggest investors in the
company
like a 90 year old dude and this lady
elizabeth
she was like being like really buddy
buddy to this guy because he was one of
the biggest investors and they were like
at family dinners and christmas parties
oh yeah she is real zuckerberg looking
too with those eyes like 30 minutes
though
oh yeah that one's only 30 minutes you
have to watch six hours yeah she's
trying to pull off the like
full-on mark zuckerberg steve jobs weird
thing
weird-looking
and this young kid jacked up on adderall
and [ __ ] this kid tyler
[ __ ] went to i forget what it was i
think was the wall street journal
and went to one of the investigative
reporters and basically [ __ ] snitched
her out on
everything basically said this because
they already they already were like they
spelled blood in the water like
something's fishy about this company
and he basically told them everything
spilled the beans spilled the beans
and here's one this is a 45 minute uh
plea no him he didn't do anything he
actually went to his grandfather
and said this is what's going on yeah
and he didn't believe him his
grandfather was like
you know you don't know everything you
don't this you know that he's like
grandpa you're dumping millions of
dollars into things you got your buddies
all investing i'm telling you this [ __ ]
doesn't work i'm on
i'm on the inside in the labs everybody
knows it doesn't work
now now you're just a young man she's a
genius
god damn like 25 years old and the
craziest [ __ ] is
sh this [ __ ] had harvey weinstein's
lawyer
nice representing their company this guy
also represented enron i think
oh yeah you understand and everybody you
sign a non-disclosure coming in and
non-disclosure
leaving didn't did one guy
commit suicide yes one guy commits one
of the scientists committed to
suicide because like some sort of
pathology stuff what
yeah it really was a lot like science it
reminded me of scientology really
yeah the whole thing did because it was
just a [ __ ] scam it's like they just
want to prop up this big picture
because nothing's really happening
behind the doors that's all that's enron
that's all
of course l ron hubbard
yeah they're all ponzi schemes that's
the guy are you taking those gummies
what are you doing
yeah he's on it bro
he's connecting the dots there's no dots
we're on a different level than you
right now matt cox
yeah that's the we're on a whole nother
dimension politics we're in another
dimension right now
um yeah bro
they keep saying she's looking at 20
years 20 years i'm telling you right now
i can't believe they're saying 20. yeah
i can't believe it's not
way more than i know right how much did
you steal look how much this [ __ ]
and honestly this went on and you got 26
and you only stole like six million
yeah but she's got weinstein's lawyer
no she doesn't the cup oh yeah she does
have one she probably doesn't now
yeah how much time did uh bernie
150 years 150 oh yeah he's done how much
money did he steal
you know he works at commissary right
really yeah they all day long you can
hear him calling out
inmates names like um really yeah he's
like
zero johnson401 one seven you know yo
but the only promise
the only difference four zero zero five
you call your name and then they tell
you what window to go to matt the only
difference between
her and madoff was that madoff was very
conscious
that he was running a ponzi scheme and
he was very aware he was never going to
pay anybody back
i think this lady thought this lady
thought that eventually
eventually this [ __ ] could actually
happen madoff didn't start his company
like that you know he didn't
start off immediately saying this is a
ponzi scheme i'm gonna go as long as i
can
he he was like chairman of the of the
stock exchange and stuff you know he was
a legitimate guy he had a legitimate
company it morphed
most of these morph into that do you see
what i'm saying look if
you want to know one of one of the ways
to know that he knew from the beginning
it wasn't going to be
a huge scam because he he
started the money or he started it with
his own money and he did in his own name
if you're running a ponzi scheme yeah
and i'm gonna project
false earnings one even if i started
with my own name
i wouldn't start i wouldn't start it in
my name
you know you would you would put
somebody else's the front man
you would or you would use a false
identity or you
there's a thousand ways to do it it's
something that started off
as a legitimate and then he started
providing false um you know false
earnings uh
or false returns and then it got to the
point where it was like
okay i can never make up for this i'm
not even going to invest anymore i'm
just going to ride into the wheel i'm
just
yeah i just ride this [ __ ] out maybe i
can go keep in mind the longer you go
the more
emboldened you are then he gets
investigated several times
he actually passes the audits
you pass the audit with no trades no
because they're oh no
well what what did you do oh i did this
and this and this
looks good bernie thanks a lot so
every time he did that he just got more
emboldened probably thought look
i'll ride this [ __ ] like i'll never
quit i'm never gonna can never retire
but maybe i'll just die of cancer and
something and then they'll figure it out
when i'm gone or you know who knows what
he's thinking but
the one thing you can't do is stop you
know that's the same and with her i
think it's the same thing i think she
started thinking
i'm going to fake it till i make it
right and then
we're going to come up with these
revolutionary things because all she was
saying is like the test
the tests already exist but you need a
machine this big
we just have to really shrink the
technology and how often is that
look at the first cell phone the first
cell phone was a brick it was this big
we shrunk it down to where honestly it's
not even this you can have all
everything in this you can have
in your ear in just a little thing
people just don't do it it's too
expensive but the point is she could
she was thinking just shrink the
technology seems simple but the problem
is she was
you know she did it's the same thing
that i think most of these
you know psychopaths do is that one
she's not thinking
thinking it through she doesn't care
about the ramifications
she's planning it all but the big thing
is she's promising too big
you're saying this machine can do the
300 known tests on blood
what are you doing who no not you i'm
just saying in general why would you say
300
right why wouldn't you have just taken
like the core ones that you could
you knew you would get right well you
don't need to test for 100
right do you really need to test to make
sure you don't have
[ __ ] disease that's already been
eradicated like oh we're testing for
smallpox there's no smallpox
this doesn't even exist well we're going
to test for it yeah but you need a
machine this big to test for what are
you doing
why are you throwing that one in there
you've you need a room this size to run
all the tests that you're saying you're
gonna
fit into what's basically the size of a
cpu
what do you do you can't do it you know
so it's like why would you
it's like these ponzi scheme guys you
know how they get caught right away
most of them get caught right away why
bernie madoff went so long is bernie
madoff was giving you
eight to ten percent um returns like
well i think it was between like six to
eight percent it was it wasn't it wasn't
outrageous
but it's consistent your money was
secure it's these guys that say
you're going to get 140 return okay well
great you can maybe go two years if you
can keep borrowing and then it all
collapses
you're just an idiot yeah you got
swamped right away yeah we got the money
in yeah but you you lasted two years and
then you had to go to prison for 10.
you know so it's like how do you want to
you want to have a real run you want to
really
raise someone be reasonable don't say
300
because not just that if you raise
enough money and you put it into the the
that you put it into r d you might pull
it off
right right we just keep doing this off
keep developing it make it better you
know
right that's actually some more you have
to start with 300.
she was thinking we're gonna [ __ ]
pull this off before the feds come in
we gotta pull it off before the feds
come in
but the craziest thing is she kept
raising money
by getting all these bad asses to join
her company yeah yeah she got through
what she was doing she got the best
scientists
the best known political contacts
well-respected scientists in the country
she hired them to work for them
put them on the front page of her
website so when she went to go get
investment money like oh [ __ ] she's got
these people
but but these scientists once they start
working they're like nothing works
like i don't care uh go go work in hr or
something
let's try it we're gonna transfer you
you're still to work here but you're not
going to do science because you know the
science is so [ __ ] up oh you know what
i love that when she would have that
people come in
like you're going to possibly invest or
you're one of the investors or maybe
you're
thinking about investing she'd have them
come in and check
everything yeah well and this is the
machine
go ahead let's take the sample of blood
okay now you place it in here
okay all right it and then start
okay it's going to take a while let's go
in the other room and have some
some uh we have hors d'oeuvres and we
want you to meet bob
the top scientist walks in the other
room another lab tech comes sneaks in
pulls out the [ __ ] blood goes into
the other room runs a bunch of tests
with it comes back an hour later
sticks it back in the machine sticks
this [ __ ] and then when they your
it should be done by now let's go back
in there she walks back in pulls it out
and goes
oh so oh so you're diabetic i am
diabetic
sold i also see that you have this and
this you know you might want to get a
cat scan
you know this is what's going on
and they said she didn't do it once she
did they did it over
and over and over so how is she now
going to get on the stand and be like
i had no idea the technology wasn't
going to work right you've been running
a scam for 10 years right
right that was just creative financing
yeah yeah
but the whole thing was a good lawyer
the whole like the biggest kicker
the biggest selling point of the whole
thing was it's only a drop of blood
but people are going into walgreens and
they're doing regular blood draws yeah
it never worked
like what the [ __ ] is this i supposed to
get your pick my finger you're pulling
out
a [ __ ] whole vial of blood it's just
that's just
the p oh oh oh the blood that's just
marketing
that's just good marketing now let's now
let's get that video that's just good
for the first
you think the quarter pounder really
weighs a quarter pound
she just she's something else boy she's
literally
they're she's [ __ ]
would you be pissed off if she only got
20. she'll probably go to a nice prison
though right
i wouldn't be pissed off it it's
it's a money crime which is horrific i'm
not saying it's not horrific
but god i don't know 20 years that's
that's a long time but but honestly
what were you thinking i mean i i'm
that's that's bad you almost
typically i am typically always like
you know what it's too much time because
it's almost always too much time but
my god i mean we're talking about almost
a billion dollars of the course of 10
years i mean
you could have it at many she has some
mental illness
you understand first of all first of all
if you knew it was a scam
money's gonna be you know if you knew
you're gonna put some money away
do something you know this is coming
down nothing i'll bet you she didn't put
nothing that way
secondly the the other thing is um
there's got to be a mental illness there
because definitely
she's she's she's was unwilling to
accept that that it wasn't gonna work
and she's threatening and she's doing it
like like why didn't you
claim bankruptcy i mean when it once it
wasn't coming together and you knew she
just kept raising money and raising
money and raising yeah that's where she
went wrong what are you doing i mean i
mean
there's got to be plus the the baritone
the the wearing the sweaters the i mean
she's crazy it's got to be like a mental
illness i mean
what do you think she has diagnosis oh i
mean she's absolutely narcissistic she's
got anti-sociopathic
disorder for sure she's either a
sociopath or a psycho but probably a
psychopath because it seems like
because she's she's got good
organizational skills
you know she's able to at the very least
she's able to fake relationships with
people
you know which is basically what i have
charming
yeah she's super charming super charming
um
but definitely narcissistic she's very
concerned about her image
she also knew that the image was part of
the whole
kind of scam like i
i don't know it's tough bro that's a
that's tough yeah
but definitely listen what what is she
why would you go to trial unless they
just came out of the gate and said take
20.
and she's like [ __ ] it the problem with
this by the way is you understand a lot
of times people will be like well the
most i can give you 20.
and you go okay and then you get
sentence and the judge says yeah you got
15 charges
kingpin yeah i want no
what do they call it these the guys just
always call it this um
uh tr where they uh where is it when you
have a train
they're gonna they're gonna stack it
whatever they'd say and they're going to
stack them instead of running them you
know
at the same time like concurrently
they're going to run consecutively and
then they're just going to stack the
charges so
you're 20 years yeah but you got 10
charges so it's 200 years
my lawyer said no matter what your
lawyer what if she doesn't get any jail
time
she won't there's no way she's not
getting jail time really there's no way
she's getting jail time she got a really
good lawyer matt cox
who she has she's getting she's going to
prison
if they if they hit her bro she going to
coleman any
no coleman they just they're turning it
into a men's camp
oh no more women's game no it's ever the
whole complex is now male
really yeah they're going to move all
the women out and transfer it to
men why are they doing that you know i
didn't get a memo
i don't know i thought you were selling
the mailing list no i just i i heard it
um so yeah but yeah they didn't send you
a christmas card
no
[Laughter]